hello friends welcome to the last in the
final part of the Trexler counterattack
in this lecture I'm going to cover what
you should do when white responded with
the move Bishop captures f7 and also
after Knight captures f7 Bishop captures
f2 instead of taking that Bishop white
King just run away to the f1 square
please note that at this point White
King goes to the e2 square then it just
gives the free tempo to the black knight
so that cannot be good so the most
critical square is King to have fun
after this move what is seriously
posting a question to the black cam what
is going to do about your two major
pieces well here the force more is Queen
to e7 and now white has two choices if
white capture the bishop first then
there comes Luke to f8 so now we are
tracking that night
and to illustrate how dangerous this
position is let me show you one of my
best game in this line so here my
opponent responded with the move d3
now white cannot casually just develop
queenside pieces for example if white
plays the move Knight to c3 then Queen
to see fire not only regain the piece
but black emerge with winning position
so that's why d3 is almost forced here I
responded with our one of the trademark
move that is the move D Phi and once
again white has limited choices if I
place the move Bishop captures D Phi
then that comes Knight captures d5 and
after pawn captures night we can simply
snip off that night and now we are
threatening a checkmate
except that y just have to give up the
Queen after Queen to f3 you can snap up
the d5 pawn and White Queen as a column
so that's why he captures defy is forced
at this position after this we are
certainly giving this check and the best
more here is king - even after this we
are going to take that night once again
we are threatening a checkmate on f2 so
the only way to defend this is to play
the move Queen to f3
afterwards we'll play the move Queen to
g6 hitting the Queen and after Queen to
g3 now comes very good move that is
night to t4 so you can see almost this
moves are forced and right now black has
created two threats that is Knight
captures c2 and rook to f2 which white
cannot parry both of them in the game my
opponent responded with the move Bishop
to b3 but after rook to f2 he realized
that how bad his position is
under the pressure he made a blunder
move that is ash tree and now I give you
a few minutes can you finish the white
off
okay so it started with the MOOC - II -
check and after came to d1 we have in
the night - f - and this will more or
less why to give up the Queen
so that was about keying captious f2 the
most critical tries Knight captures
hatchet afterwards once again we are
going to play our trademark move that is
the move d5 so hitting the bishop now
White has three possibilities over here
the first one is Bishop captures defy
because after this move we are going to
simply play the move Bishop to g4 and
bye-bye miss Queen rather nice the
second move white can try is now
capturing the bishop at this juncture so
white is grabbing all the material and
saying black Hey what you are up to well
there's a saying in chess do not become
too greedy and this is exactly the case
over here to illustrate how dangerous
white position is let me show you one of
my game here I responded with the move
d captured c4 and my opponent responded
with the mood Knight to c3 so he just
want to develop his Queen side pieces
here I played the move Bishop to g4
attacking the Queen the Queen drops to
the even but actually it's a mistake
the reason is now I can jump to the d4
square unthreatening to play Knight
captures c2
after a long thinking my opponent come
up with the move rook to be won but here
I grab the c2 pawn anyways and my
opponent responded here with the move
Queen to f1 so he's attacking now c4
which I defended with the move Bishop to
e6 he played the move
d3 here I responded very very
energetically so I played the move
castling on the Queen side and my
opponent thought that why can't I just
disturbed the coordination of the black
piece so he played the move Knight to
have seven which at the end comes out as
a mistake I played the Moon Knight to g4
check and please note that King to g1 we
leads to the checkmate sequence after
Queen to C file checker so the only good
more here is King to e2 afterwards I
give another check that is C captures d3
and once again
my response is force white has to go to
the D 2 square and now I capture that
night
and if you look at this position you can
clearly see there is a traffic jam on
the back rank of the white side and not
only that black pcs are so much
aggressively placed
pressure creates a mistake and that was
happened in the game
after the move s3 I just played the move
Queen to g5 and my opponent has to give
up the resignation immediately
so that was about King 2f2 the best move
over here is he captures defy but after
this once again black and played the
move Knight to d4 I have reached this
position many time in my games and
mainly three of the Tri has been done in
the first game
my opponent try the move Knight to c3 I
played the move Bishop to g4 so
attacking the Queen so white has the
only reply laughs that is blocking the
file with the move Bishop to e2 I
capture that bishop and after Knight
captures Bishop
I played a very strong move that is
Queen to f8 so there are some nasty
looming on their file which why it needs
to be very very careful
getting annoyed by that peen my opponent
is pointed over here with the MU s3 but
after Bishop to h5
I was 100% sure that he's going to play
the Mooji for which I was waiting for
because now I can sacrifice my night and
after H captures and Bishop captures
once again we have the traffic jam
scenario on the back rank this is the
worst case because we are threatening a
checkmate after a very long thinking my
opponent played the move d3 but after my
next move that is Bishop to e3 his King
is a goner so there is a check Mitch
the second mode tried over here is the
move c3 once again we are going to play
the move Bishop to g4 and now this time
around why has the only move left that
is Queen to a four check which we are
going to block by our Knight
it's true that two of the black pieces
are hanging right now but white cannot
touch either of them for example if
white takes the move C captures v4 then
here comes Queen to f6 so once again
this familiar trap exists where we are
going to checkmate the white king
and please note that D captures Aoife
doesn't change the scenario because
black can simply play the move Queen to
f4 and the threat remain as it is
instead of capturing the night if white
takes the bishop then this is even worst
because now we can give this Queen check
and after g3 we can give Queen to f6
check and after King to even we have
this wonderful move that is green to a
file there are some nasty threats are
looming the first obvious one is night
to see to check and not only that black
is also threatening to play the move
Queen to e4
the best more suggested over here by
Fritz is C captures v4 but after this
black can play the move Queen to e4
check and after King to f2 black queen
can simply capture the rook in the
corner and yet the threats are not over
right now black is threatening to
capture the bishop is threatening to
capture the h2 and any moment that can
castle on the Queen side
in this game my opponent responded with
the Moon Knight to c3 so saving the
bishop but after Queen to h2 check he
casually played the MU King to even
which cost in the game so there's a mate
in two
first of all Queen to Jeevan check and
after that only reply fish up to a phone
queen to g3 as a checkmate
last but not least at this position
white has also captured this bishop
but this is just asking for it so here
obviously like is going to start with
the Moon Knight to g4 check and if the
King goes to the g3 then Queen to G Phi
is very strong accordingly if the King
goes to the g1 then Queen to C Phi is a
very strong mu the best move over here
is king - even after this we are going
to play the move Queen to f6 so
threatening a checkmate the only good
way to defend is the move rook to a fun
we have another Queen check and after g3
we just capture - to pawn and now good
thing is the g3 is hanging but there is
no way white can defend this there's a
one-game my opponent responded with the
move rook to a3 after just one move that
is evil he's just lost the best move
over here is the move d3 black can
capture the c2 pawn with a check so
white has no option but to capture this
night and now black is going to capture
the screen
Black has queen for the three pcs but
because the lack of development and miss
coordination of the white your computer
will definitely give heavy age to the
black camp
so with this variations we can easily
conclude that King to have fun is a good
move but is a rather dull mu and we can
allow Y to capture the rook in the
corner but in return we get tremendous
attack on the White King it's time to
look at Bishop captures Epsilon
the third alternative for the white
player is to play Bishop captures f7 and
I think this will be the case for many
positional player what they actually
want to do is instead of broiling into
the nine clutches at seven line they
just want to be a pawn up and miss plays
the black King so they can hold on to
that phone and rest of the game well as
a Traxler you should be more than happy
because here you don't need to even
sacrifice heavy material still you get a
very good position
now the first point you should notice is
after King to e7 white has to
immediately evacuate his bishop because
if he play a casual move such as
castling at this point which looks very
attractive but after the move at six
White will definitely lose a piece so
that's why there are two squares this
Bishop can go doesn't matter with square
the bishop is go over planning of
campaign will remain the same so let's
say the ship goes to the b3 and now what
is indeed threatening the move Knight to
f7 which to his surprise we are going to
allow him why the move d6
so at first sight it looks completely
stupid because not only white wind upon
him is place of a king and now also
allowing night at 7:00 so it's
completely look ridiculous but it
contains big surprises let's see what
will happen if white plays the move
Knight wraps em
well here the black response is force
black has to play the move Queen to FH
and now as I highlighted by the arrows
over here White has try few options now
the first obvious movies Knight captures
a chit well after this there is a mating
sequence start with the move Bishop
captures f2
here the king catches f2 his force
because if the king goes to the f1
square then after Bishop to g4
the queen is trapped once again so
that's not possible that means King
captures up to his force and now we are
going to play the move Knight captures
e4 however white plays his King is not
going to survive so for example if King
goes to the e3 then we have Queen to
have to check and after King captures e4
he have Bishop to f5 check and after
King to defy we have checkmate with the
move Queen to d4 so that's why Knight
captures H it is prohibited the second
move white can try is the move d3 but
after the move d3 black and once again
play of a typical sacrifice move that is
Bishop captures f2 and after King
captures f2 now we are going to play the
move Knight to d4
Knight to d4 has a very simple idea
Knight wants to capture the bishop and
then captures the knight question is how
white is going to stop this plan for
example if white foolishly remove the
night let's say it goes to the g5
then after Knight captures efore no
matter where the White King is go the
mate is on the next moon
so that's not possible and if I try to
be saved the bishop why the move Bishop
to c4 then defy is extremely strong
the third move I can try is the Moon
Knight to c3 but this can hardly
describe a good move because once again
we can play the move Knight to d4 and
the idea is very simple we want to
capture the bishop and then capture the
knight and please note if the bishop
goes to the c4 then I can always play
the movie file so accordingly the best
move suggested over here is Knight
captures h8 well now black has a very
good sequence which confirms the
advantage so here black capture the
bishop and after white recapture we play
our trademark move that is Bishop
captures f2 if the King goes to the f1
square then Bishop to g4 is a very
strong move if now white play the move
Knight to e2 to save the queen then
there comes a knight captures efore and
although I can play many moves at this
position there is a force made in 14
moves so you can see how dangerous these
positions if white plays one or two
inaccurate moves
King captures f2 doesn't change the
scenario because black is always going
to capture the e4 pawn with a double
check and made to follow some of you
might wonder hang on why can't just
white played the simple move that is
castle say Fanny skiing and then White
has no problem at all what is black
going to do about it well here is the
answer first black is going to play the
move Bishop to g4 attacking the Queen
so Queen has to go to the even square
and now black plays the move Knight to
d4 so idea is very much similar Black
Knight wants to capture the bishop and
then captures the knight well if that's
the case then you may ask the question
then why can't quite capture the rook
what's wrong about it
well this is a typical trap where many
people has fallen into and you should
watch this trap carefully so here black
play is a very good move that is Queen
to CH now what's the idea of going to
see it
well the first idea is revealed when
some of my opponents plays the move c3
just hoping that that night will go back
well here comes the big blow
Knight to f3 BAM so it's a fork so what
is obliged to capture that night and
after she catches f3 and Bishop captures
f3 that is unstoppable maid is coming up
well if not c3 what about if the King
moves away so for example if King - h1
then instead of Knight to f3 this time
the other piece join into the body which
is Bishop f3 BAM
Bishop is spinning the G to spawn so now
Queen to s3 is on the agenda and if y
capture this Bishop then Knight catches
r3 there is a hit on the Queen so Queen
has to move and when the Queen moves we
are going to play the move Queen to h3
and then mate on h2 is following
so this has some of the wonderful tricks
exist if you opponent greedily put night
on f7
finally I like to conclude this section
with showing one game where what happens
if white employed for example after
Bishop to d4 and you play the move d6
does not commit night to f7 but place a
recommended move which is suggested by
many books and videos that is the move
c3
well against this I'm going to show you
one of my own game which will give you a
very good idea how to handle this sort
of scenarios here I responded with the
move Queen to eh and my opponent who was
around 2100 rated responded with the
obvious looking move that is castle I
responded very energetically with the
move Bishop to g4 and he responded with
the move Queen to b3 so his idea is to
capture the b7 pawn well first I give a
nudge to the knight with the move at six
and now white response is force white
cannot capture the b7 pawn if he would
have capture the b7 pawn then following
sequence will emerge black with a
winning position so here black should
continue with the move Knight captures
defy and after pawn captures black
should immediately capture tonight the
simple reason is when white regain his
piece now comes the very strong move
that is Queen to h5 so there is a maid
threatened on h2
what can continue for one more check
that is screen capture c7 but after King
to f6 black king is quite safer at this
place and now in the view of made on h2
what has to forcefully play the move h3
afterwards
any beginner can guessed it yep it's
Bishop capture as three and even a GM
can hardly survive in this sort of
position so that's why at this point he
played the accurate move that is Knight
to e6 but then I raised the complication
with the move Knight to a5 now Knight
captures g7 is technically not walking
so that means White Queen has to move he
plays the Queen on the C 2 square but
after this I played the another strong
move that is Queen to g6
so now idea is very simple either Bishop
to f3 or Bishop to h3 will be played on
the right time my opponent responded
over here with the move d4 but just to
mention if white plays an inaccurate
move such as King to h1 then after
Knight captures defy white will simply
lose a piece
after the moody four I captured the
bishop he captured my bishop and then I
created a checkmate trade with the move
Bishop to f3 he defended with the MU g3
and now I capture the night after the
whole sequence black emerged with a
clear piece up
he was desperate to get his piece back
so he played the move Knight to d2 I
responded with the move Bishop to e2 and
after rook t1 I hold on to my piece with
the move Knight to f4 now if you
carefully look at this position wide
species are coming in each other ways so
there is no coordination happening in
the white camp my opponent was desperate
to get his piece back so he first of all
captured the pawn I played the rook to a
fade and now he played the move Queen to
e4 which is a typical mistake happen in
the time trouble I give you a few
minutes over here it's black to play and
you need to finish your opponent
okay I hope you find this move that is
Knight to h3 check and after King to h1
we have the winning move that is Queen
to g4 so now the idea is to play Bishop
to f3 and if rook captures Bishop then
Queen captures rook and then there is no
escape
with this we are concluding the
wonderful world of the Plex will
counter-attack
I hope my Alice's has given you enough
information to explore the wonderful
world of the Trexler before we leave I
like to mention one important resource
for the Trexler counterattack in case if
you want to learn a good theory there is
one good chess base DVD by Robert Reis
which covers the Trachsel attack in
detail and also he has suggested some
nice lines again the different Italian
set oh well thank you for watching this
video feel free to like subscribe and
comment I'll meet you in my next lecture
bye